some breaking news to bring you now from
uganda and there are reports that the
military have surrounded the home of the
main opposition candidate
in the country's elections ahead of
results uh being announced our africa
correspondent john sparks is on the
phone
for us john uh this is bobby wines house
yes that's right it's uh bobby wines
house uh
real name robert chagilani he has a
large house
located about an hour outside of the
capital
kampala and he sent out a couple of
panicky sounding tweets this afternoon
saying that
members of the military were encroaching
on his
property that his property had been
essentially surrounded by
the military we drove out there as
quickly as we could
and we found bobby wine
at the the edge of the the lawn which uh
there's been a gate and a fence and a
hill which leads down to
more of his property which is forested
we found him
uh somewhat anxiously examining the
property he told us that
he had seen troops soldiers
on the property that they had come and
beat one of his
guards up and we were introduced to the
guard who had
uh suffered some uh facial injuries and
then
he took us and a small number of other
journalists
on a tour of his property we went down a
hill
into some of the trees round the corner
and we saw a group of about
five uniformed men armed with
automatic weapons one of them picked up
his weapon
and uh pointed it at us and we
along with bobby wine ran for cover
i must say that at the stage was one of
the weapons discharged but it was
a frightening experience we ran back up
to the main
house had a chat with bobby wein he said
that this was an example of
the intimidation that he has faced
during the campaign
increasing intimidation now that the
election results
are expected they are expected to be
delivered by the
election commission tomorrow and he said
that the
government was putting him in his place
uh it's certainly an unusual highly
unusual way
to treat a presidential candidate uh in
this election or in any election he has
run a very strong campaign he has
fired up certainly younger members of
the electorate in this
uh country it does sound and look
like government intimidation to me
on another side of the property through
a chain link fence we could see
soldiers and plane clothes men with
armed weapons as well i tried to speak
to them
they said nothing it does look like a
clear attempt
at intimidation and
very uncomfortable position for for
bobby wine who is the
the country's best known most effective
opposition leader
it's very uncomfortable place for him to
be in at the moment